CNN's Chris Cuomo defends anti feh the
mainstream media failed to report on a
foiled Islamic terror plot and leftists
embrace the hijab I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
there are very fine people on both sides
of left-wing terrorism I guess that's
what seems to be the case according to
CNN and Chris Cuomo no minor media
figure by the way Chris Cuomo whose
brothers Andrew Cuomo Democrat governor
of New York whose father was Mario Cuomo
major Democrat governor of New York
Chris Cuomo coming out in favor and and
defending an Tifa he's speaking out of
both sides of his mouth he says I'm not
defending an Tifa but come on these guys
are pretty good we'll take a look at
that in one second and explain as always
why the left gets things exactly
backwards they get it backwards on
violence they get it backwards on dirty
tricks they get it backwards on the
media they even get it backwards on
popular culture on the hijab on sports
it's a it's a really crass moment right
now for the left as they go on the
attack against conservatives for being
violent but first wise company oh you
know that you need to be prepared in any
sort of emergency wise company takes an
innovative approach in providing
dependable simple and affordable
freeze-dried food for emergency
preparedness and outdoor use wise
company meals are designed to protect
your most valuable asset your family
when government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks before you
can get to fresh food and water you
cannot rely on someone else you have to
rely on yourself you can't know what
tomorrow may bring but you can have
peace of mind knowing that you'll be
ready with all you need you've been
reading the news a lot of pretty scary
events out there violence political
uncertainty don't put yourself in a
situation where you need something that
you don't have get prepared today not
only is wise emergency food excellent it
tastes very good the quality is
unmatched
they don't just slap their name on some
other product that someone else gave
them all their ingredients our chef's
prepare to internally by wise company by
doing
they cut out the middleman they pass the
savings on to you there is no excuse in
waiting until it is too late there's no
better time to prepare that now wise
emergency food is an investment in peace
of mind for your family this week my
listeners can get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product at an extra 25
percent off the lowest marked price at
wise food storage calm when entering
Noel's ko wles a check out or by calling
eight five five four five three two nine
four five plus shipping is free wise as
a 90 day no questions asked return
policy so there's no risk in taking the
initiative to get yourself and your
family more prepared today that's wise
food storage compro my god no 'ls get
any wise emergency right door food
product extra 25% off and free shipping
we have been hearing for weeks now
actually we've been hearing this for
years but it's ramped up in recent weeks
how awful it is the Donald Trump and
Trump supporters defended the neo-nazis
at Charlottesville now you know that
never happened he never defended them
well we've been told it's awful that he
drew a moral equivalence between
peaceful protesters and neo-nazis he
never did that well it's awful that he
said that there were fine people among
the neo-nazis he never did that we've
been hearing this ramping up for weeks
and weeks and weeks meanwhile Chris
Cuomo on CNN defends and Tifa a domestic
terror organization here he is talk
about anti feh I've watched them in the
streets protesting in different
situations okay
there are certainly aspects of them that
are true to a cause that is a good cause
they want social justice they want
whatever they want in that context you
Tonia t this ever happens you tell me
when that has ever happened with
neo-nazis where they have ever been
doing and to write a good cause and Tifa
does not have good aims and Tifa wants
power once political power taken through
force
that's what antifa is all about I mean
are these and Brian not here to espouse
an tyfa or any group on the political I
get no because
you want it to be like that because you
want it to be simple no and you want to
be able to run away after something like
this and say Cuomo loves the alt left he
loves them and you know it's not true
you know it's BS what I'm saying is this
you don't draw a moral equivalence
between neo-nazis and the people there
to fight against them you don't do it in
that context because it's not what we
are about in this country first of all
it is simple antiva are terrorists they
are domestic terrorists who use violence
to affect their political ends it is
simple he says that his people on the
panel want this to seem like a simple
discussion it is simple and Tifa or
terrorists also Chris Cuomo at the
beginning of that clip and at the end of
that clip defends antiva at the
beginning of it he says look there were
elements in an Tifa which are really
good you know they want really good
things no there aren't they are
terrorists they were black face masks
and they go out explicitly and
exclusively to commit violence they're
not good people none of them work there
are no very fine people in antiva then
at the end he says no no that's not
really what I'm saying I'm just saying
that you can't draw a moral equivalence
between Nazis and the people fighting
against them between fascists and the
people fighting against fascists
by the way antifa or fascists they use
the tactics of fascists they have
fascist goals they even dress like
fascists they wear the black shirts
which are the mark of Italian fascists
the people who invented fascism so you
not only can you draw a moral
equivalence they are equivalent but what
Chris Cuomo is saying is actually a
little a little bit of a grandeur claim
than that he's not saying that they're
equivalent what he's saying is that
antifa are better because there are some
good people because there are some very
fine people on both sides according to
the FBI and the Department of Homeland
Security and Tifa are domestic
terrorists it's not just a term were
throwing around that's according to the
federal government what have we seen an
Tifa do well you saw one of those guys
bust in and attack me when I was trying
to
a speech at the University of Missouri
Kansas City a few weeks ago you saw this
at Tucker Carlson's house a group of
Antigua terrorists show up at his house
tried to bust in his door break his
front door chase his wife so she has to
hide in the pantry until someone can
come home until the cops can get there
and then outside of his house they
chanted quote Tucker Carlson we will
fight we know where you sleep at night
Tucker Carlson what crime has Tucker
Carlson committed he hosts a television
show on cable that they don't like so
they go they break his property they
deface his property they drew big
anarchist symbols and paint on his house
and they terrify his wife and then they
threaten him where he sleeps at night
but according to Chris Cuomo there are
some good people they have some good
aims they have some good goals now we're
just learning there's a new FBI report
out that antiva has been coordinating
with a Mexican cartel leader to try to
start a rebellion a violent rebellion on
the border and attack our Border Patrol
agents and attack our military and
attack our federal officials so they
were working with a Mexican cartel
leader named Cobra Commander whose other
nickname is the Mexican Rambo they sound
like good people don't they good people
I'm about very fine people on both sides
what they were what they were working
with this cartel leader for according to
the FBI report is to get weapons for
their group from a Mexican cartel and
then use those weapons to kill cops and
to kill Border Patrol agents and to
cause disruption along the border and
Tifa working with Mexican cartel leaders
to buy guns to kill cops very good
people very fine people on both sides
the FBI report writes quote they were
working together to set up camps to
Train activists and become quote
community defense militias what does
that mean goes on organizers planned for
the camps to be used as staging
platforms from which five person units
would
formed to train anarchists in fighting
combat and conducting reconnaissance and
then launch to disrupt US government
operations along the border very fine
people specifically one of the people
that apparently was behind this was an
activist named Evan Duke so you've got
one of the biggest voices in the
mainstream media and one of the most
mainstream this guy Chris Cuomo is at
the heart of Democrat politics you also
have major figures in academia and not
just some fringe lunatic professor from
Cal State LA you've got a professor at
Dartmouth College one of the oldest
colleges in the country older than the
United States
mark Bray going out and saying the same
thing Chris Cuomo just didn't accept
even a little bit more clearly in Tifa
yeah they can be pretty good people the
question if we will take a big step back
historically and say all right when was
it legitimate to stand up and defend
oneself against fascism in the 20s and
30s how bad did it have to get now today
is not the same as the 20s and 30s but
there are enough parallels for us to be
having this conversation and so the
question is how bad does it have to get
to defend oneself anti-fascist argue you
don't let it take the first step you
stand up to it sometimes in a
pre-emptive self-defense and that's sort
of something that people have trouble
grappling with but they argue don't let
it grow powerful enough until it's
actually at your front door well I mean
that's a fairly controversial thing to
say pre-emptive defense meaning you hit
first that's gonna rub some people the
wrong way obviously pre-emptive
self-defense if that is not the most
Orwellian phase you've ever heard
violent peace peaceful war pre-emptive
self-defense speaking of safety rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
you know about ring I talk about it all
the time ring has a smart video doorbell
and camera that can protect millions of
people everywhere and does ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if some wacko an tyfa
guy with a weird mask on his face shows
up to your door you'll be able to see
him you'll also be able to communicate
with him you'll get an alert and you
will talk to an all from your phone
whether you're in your house whether you
are at the office whether you are on
vacation wherever you can talk to them
that is thanks to the HD video and
two-way audio features on
ringg devices i will say as somebody who
gets threats with with some regularity
as you know as somebody who when i go to
these colleges occasionally gets
physically assaulted it makes me feel a
lot safer to have ring I give Ranaut to
all my friends as housewarming gifts our
senior producer J Hay has ring to Wakko
drug-addled people showed up to his
house at 3:00 in the morning he spoke to
them from his bedroom let them know
somebody was at home they skedaddled
because they didn't want to have to deal
with somebody and they didn't want to be
seen and that video gets uploaded to the
cloud so you'll be able to identify
whoever that is even if they steal your
ring by the way it'll already be in the
cloud so you can send it to the cops as
a listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and motion
activated flood light camera the starter
kit has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home go to ring.com slash Knowles Keo
wles ring.com
slash Knowles that Professor mark Bray
professor at Dartmouth wrote a book
encouraging antifa called the
anti-fascist handbook mark Bray comes up
with a clever little defense of the ante
fuh terrorist tactics he calls it
pre-emptive self-defense you know it's
one of those phrases that sort of say if
you're not paying attention
it sounds oh yeah okay that's
pre-emptive self-defense okay that makes
sense
self-defense can't be pre-emptive it's
like when people talk about violent
speech speech is not violent speech does
not commit violence when people equate
speech and violence no no there's
violence and then their speech
there's self-defense and then there's
preemption pre-emptive self-defense
means aggression it shows as we notice a
lot that the left always wants the
appearance of the thing but they don't
want the reality of the thing they want
all the trappings of the thing they
don't want the essence of the thing they
want to seem like they're just playing
defense there are the victims
they're being attacked and they are just
defending themselves but they're not
gonna wait until they get attacked
because nobody's really attacking them
so what they do is they go out and they
commit violence unprovoked unjustified
and then they say no it was self-defense
how was it self-defense you went up to
that conservative speaker and
sucker-punched him
oh well no you don't that was
pre-emptive self-defense pre-emptive
self-defense why did you go up to that
conservative speaker and sucker punch
him oh well because he actually
committed violence on me with his words
well from my vantage it looks like
conservative speakers are they're
talking and then leftist thugs go up and
physically attack them no no no no no
it's pre-emptive self-defense that's
what they're saying
now the left is not peaceful at the
moment the left is not advocating for
peace the left is advocating for
violence in their rhetoric and in these
cases where violence erupts usually it's
on the left not all the time but usually
is on the left they want to appear
primarily peaceful but they're actually
eager and encouraging of committing
violence this brings us to another
important rule to keep in mind when
you're watching the mainstream media
when you're in in class when you're
looking at politics the left accuses the
right of doing what the left actually
does you can bet on it
this this always has is always true they
accused President Trump and Trump
supporters of praising neo-nazis or of
drawing a moral equivalence between
peaceful protesters and neo-nazis Trump
never did that the left did that you
just saw it happen twice by fairly
prominent figures whenever the left that
whenever the right rather accuses the
left of something there or rather when
the I'm sorry I this is very confusing
there's the left and the right there's
violence there's an Tifa there's moral
equivalence when the left accuses the
right of something you can bet that it
is not the right that's doing it it is
the left that is doing it for instance
you look at Joe Biden Joe Biden accuses
can
servants of being racially divisive he's
going on this whole spiel now about how
we need to make him America morale again
cuz because Trump is so racist and
bigoted and awful Joe Biden said in 2012
that Mitt Romney wanted to put black
people back in Chains to a predominantly
black audience Joe Biden has been a
racial huckster his entire career and
then he goes out and launches his
campaign his entire campaign on a lie
that Donald Trump called neo-nazis fine
people in Charlottesville didn't happen
supporters of the Clintons supporters of
Bob Menendez supporters of Eliot Spitzer
of Anthony Weiner of
all sorts of Democrat sexual degenerate
are accusing Republicans and
conservatives and Trump supporters of
being unfair to women of being harsh on
women misogyny sexism
they ran Hillary Clinton last election
the woman who smeared all of her
husband's victims they they were going
to return Bill Clinton a sexual
assailant to the Oval Office he was
gonna be on the couch he wasn't gonna be
behind the desk but they were gonna
return that man to the White House how
about when Democrats accused Republicans
of colluding with the Russians for two
years they said that Republicans and
Trump colluded with the Russians for two
years they went out they made a deal
with Vladimir Putin they rigged the 2016
election they robbed it from Hillary
Clinton it's an illegitimate presidency
because it was bought and paid for by
Vladimir Putin and and Hillary and Trump
rather as a puppet of Vladimir Putin
what did we find out the only people the
only people who colluded with the
Russians were the Democrats how did they
collude with the Russians because they
paid fusion GPS to Commission an oppo
research file written by Christopher
steel which used information procured
from you guessed it the Russians where
else could that information have come
from now it turned out to have been
disinformation the Democrats literally
colluded with the Russians the federal
government
because the federal government then
under Barack Obama used that steel
dossier as a cheap excuse to get
surveillance warrants for the Trump
campaign so the federal government those
deep state agents as they're called and
the Democrats spent two years accusing
Donald Trump of doing something that not
only he didn't do that they did
themselves this is also in it comes out
and how they report on it so any time an
act of violence can be tied to the right
wing you are gonna see right away in the
headline right wing violence
conservative violence Trump supporter
violence you're gonna see that reported
on breathlessly for weeks if not years
Charlottesville is a good example of
this Charlottesville was radical
right-wing base I guess they share some
views of the left but they probably
would call themselves right-wing there's
a neo-nazi types radical fringe there
were probably 200 of them in the entire
country they go out they commit violence
Donald Trump explicitly condemns them
two years you hear the left right-wing
violence Trump supporter violence
conservative violence anytime an act of
violence can be tied to the left wing
it's buried
it's totally buried there is there was a
terrorist attack that was foiled over
the weekend a left-wing Islamic domestic
terrorist attack have you heard about
that have you read about his that bin
all over the mainstream media did you
see that on the evening news did you
read about that in the New York Times
probably not if you did it was probably
just a little story and probably it left
out a lot of details this guy Domingo
was according to prosecutors making
posts online that expressed support this
is from the prosecutors expressed
support for violent jihad a desire to
seek retribution for attacks against
Muslims and a willingness to become a
martyr he had considered attacking Jews
churches and police officers but instead
he decided he was going to detonate an
ie be in a long beach extreme right-wing
rally
on Sunday morning but the rally was
called off he posted a video last month
expressing his belief and support for
Islam okay this is a not only a
left-wing guys targeting right-wing
groups he's targeting conservative
institutions he's targeting religious
groups Jews churches how do you think
this is covered by the mainstream media
you do you think it was Islamic
terrorists plot foiled left-wing
terrorist plot well no probably not
this is how CBS reports it quote army
vet arrested in foiled terror plot
apparently wrote America needs another
Vegas event look at the brilliance look
at how clever the left is in writing
that headline so they lead with army vet
yes the guy was had been in the army
when you hear army vet do you think
right-wing guy or left-wing guy probably
you think right-wing guy there are
plenty of Democrats in the military but
you when you read that you just assume
he's a military guy he's probably on the
right then terror plot this is this is
also coming in the wake of that awful
synagogue attack last Friday and you
hear American needs another Vegas event
when what was that Vegas event we
actually don't really know much about
the motivations for that Las Vegas
shooting but what we do remember or the
responses to the Vegas shooting we know
that the left wing made a major push for
gun control after that to ban guns that
would not have stopped the attack and we
know the right defended those guns and
the Second Amendment so just even
setting up that that paradigm we need
another Vegas attack of what do I
remember about Vegas I remember the
right was was fighting for second
Amendment rights around okay and I Army
veteran okay so I don't probably not a
left-wing or how do they how do they
then open up the article quote a US Army
veteran is being held without bail
accused of plotting an attack to avenge
the killing of Muslims that's the first
sentence in the article on CB s CBS so
he's not doing it because he's a
terrorist he's not doing it be
he wants to kill innocent people he's
not doing it to advance his political
agenda no he's doing it to avenge that's
the verb they use avenge see its
defensive self-defense it's not
pre-emptive so I guess it is pre-emptive
self-defense because he's going to
avenge imagine if it were a right winger
would they use the word avenge how did
the Boston Globe report on this
California terror plot by Army veteran
stopped us officials say not by Muslim
not by left-winger no no Army veteran
hears from four also from the this
wasn't the Boston Globe I don't have the
source here another mainstream news
source Los Angeles terror plot law
enforcement prevents attack aimed at
mass mass casualties oh that was the
subtitle of the Boston Globe it's an
attack aimed at mass casualties what
kind of attack who's attacking once at
la terror plot it was a left-winger they
don't say that how about after that
shooting at the synagogue after the
po-wei shooting there was a white
supremacist who committed that shooting
that white supremacist in his manifesto
condemns Donald Trump condemns
conservatives explicitly how does the
Daily Beast report on that quote why
conservatives keep getting anti-semitism
wrong conservative conservatives are
getting it wrong it's conservative it's
really probably it's conservatives fault
even though the terrorists who shot up
that synagogue explicitly said he hates
conservatives and he's not a
conservative they go on in The Daily
Beast by detaching anti-semitism from
its nationalist ideology the right
Dodge's responsibility over and over
again for its fellow travelers
anti-semitism on the right that's what
the left is going to talk about the left
just ran in the New York Times a a
cartoon of Benjamin Netanyahu Prime
Minister of Israel as a dog leading a
blind Trump who's hunched over like a
caricature of a Jew on the Internet we
a classic trope of a Jew with a yarmulke
on his head you can compare that cartoon
to propaganda published by the Nazi
Party in 1940 they are identical there's
a similar cartoon of Jews leading
Winston Churchill like a dog walking him
right in front of them this all the same
imagery
you've got Ilan Omar an elected Democrat
congresswoman who is engaging in
anti-semitic tropes all the time
accusing Jews of being disloyal to the
United States saying the only reason to
support Israel is because it's all about
the Benjamins baby because Jews are
bribing everybody saying that Israel has
hypnotized the world and praying to
Allah to wake up people up to the evil
deeds of Israel laughing at Islamic
terrorist groups like Hamas and al-qaeda
and Hezbollah associating with groups
tied to Islamic terrorist groups
defending Islamic terrorists from
receiving their just punishment the
United States and then the left is going
to accuse the right of widespread
anti-semitism case in point
that's this is the case in point this
domestic terrorist arrested after a
foiled terror attack and you just it
just won't be reported that is what the
right is up against in this country the
endorsement of violence by a CNN anchor
the endorsement of violence by an Ivy
League professor and then smears
baseless smears from the entire
mainstream media that's what the right
is up against and there are this leads
to some dirty tricks in politics dirty
tricks on the right dirty tricks on the
left but there's a big distinction
between how the right uses dirty tricks
and how the left uses dirty tricks we'll
get to that in a second we also have to
talk about the the latest with poor old
Joe Biden and Joe Biden's having a real
rough go of it and we'll talk about
Democrats embracing the hijab and
transgenderism but first I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube head
daily wire comm 10 bucks a month $100
for an annual membership you get me you
get the Andrew Klavan show you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get them out wall
show you can test questions in the mail
back coming up on Thursday you get to
ask questions backstage you get the
another Kingdom podcast and you get the
leftist tears tumblr they taste just as
good as ever and as 2020 heats up
they're only going to get better go to
daily wire comm we'll be right back
there's even a big difference on the
left and the right in dirty tricks so
dirty tricks is it happens in every
political campaign they dig up dirt or
they make up dirt and tirely and they
try to sling it on candidates and and
people people on both sides do it
however there's a big difference in how
we do it there's a big difference in how
we engage in politics when Republican
dirty tricks are exposed the GOP tends
to acknowledge it and back off when
Democrat dirty tricks are exposed they
double down they get even more intense
here's a good example of this was
trending yesterday is this guy jacob
wool who i guess is an internet troll
basically i only know him as a twitter
account
and he's vaguely right-wing and he likes
donald trump and apparently he tried to
sling a dirty trick at pete but a judge
the idea was jacob wool cooked up this
plan to paint pete but a judge as some
kind of sexual asylum frame but a judge
for rape because he allegedly considered
but a judge a terminal threat to donald
trump the most ridiculous part of this
whole story by the way is the notion
that pete but a judge is the terminal
threat to donald trump pete but a
judge's like 12 years old and he
currently governs a city of about 15
people this guy is going to be the end
of Donald Trump's political career not
quite so sure about that but here's what
happened allegedly it was wole who was
behind this
this kid Hunter Kelly published a piece
on the website medium saying quote my
name is Hunter Kelly I'm 21 years old
this is by far the hardest thing I've
ever had to do for the past three nights
I've not slept even a single hour I've
vomited eight times I was sexually
assaulted by Mayor Pete but a judge I
didn't know who he was back in February
only that he told me he was an important
politician when I started seeing him on
television three weeks ago as a
presidential candidate I thought about
coming forward I'm a gay man I've been
grappling with my identity for a number
of years I live work and attend college
in rural Michigan I know that by coming
forward I will make a hard life even
harder but I must do so I must do so
from
country for other gay men like me and
most importantly to stop a very bad man
from becoming president of United States
I must confess that this is the toughest
thing I have ever had to do for two
weeks now I have been contemplating
suicide I see myself jumping from a
building or a bridge I know that years
and years of counseling may lie in front
of me all right if if this is a hoax
which it appears to be it's not very
well written now this kid hunter Kelley
comes out the next day says I was not
sexually assaulted by Pete but a judge I
did not write that piece somebody else
wrote that piece it was tweeted out by
Jacob wools father it was not me
a little bit of advice if you're going
to play a political dirty trick do it
well execute it well this this guy Jacob
ball is the same guy who's being accused
of trying to frame Bob Muller for rape
back during the Special Counsel
investigation before we knew that it
would exonerate Trump there was an
attempt to frame Bob Muller for rape
if you're gonna play a dirty trick maybe
don't go after the former head of the
FBI maybe that's gonna be a tougher one
to pull off mmm if you're gonna do it
maybe make sure that the mark you're
using doesn't come out and contradict
you the next day just so ridiculous
also this is very immoral this is very
wrong to sling this accusation at people
for one reason because it's a very very
very serious crime it's not like this
guy accused but a judge or smeared but a
judge as having had an extramarital
affair which is also terribly immoral
but it's not as serious a crime that's
the kind of old-school political slander
you would say oh he's sleeping around
he's cheating on his wife for cheating
on her husband or whatever this is this
guy raped me that's a very serious crime
and it needs to be treated seriously
unfortunately the left has slung these
accusations all over the place there
have been so many hoaxes especially on
college campuses proven hoaxes
demonstrated hoaxes admitted hoaxes that
now people look on a cues
of rape and sexual assault with a lot of
skepticism the left did that the right
should not exacerbate that that's a
really awful thing it's the worst thing
you can be accused of I can really think
of a very little that would be worse to
be accused of than a rape or some kind
of sexual assault very bad idea really
really awful stuff at least the right is
calling it out when this started
trending yesterday everybody was dunking
on this guy Jacob wool there were even
memes going around about it have the
left and the right are only united in
dunking on this guy Jacob wool now
you'll notice this is the first time
basically anybody is reporting even on
the suggestion that P but a judge raped
somebody why hadn't really heard about
it nobody takes these things that
seriously these kind of sensational
accusations it didn't seem to be true
and we don't want to get down in the
dirt on something like this it's a
really horrific thing what about the
left though the left has been using fake
sexual assault allegations as a cudgel
for decades
how about Anita Hill Joe Biden is
getting a lot of flack right now for how
he handled the Anita Hill accusations
against Clarence Thomas when he was
being confirmed to the Supreme Court and
he's getting flak from the left because
he wasn't able to successfully torpedo
Clarence Thomas's nomination on Anita
Hills accusations but it's worth going
back and revisiting and Nita Hills
Ella's allegations because she lied and
we know that she lied there were
discrepancies between her FBI interview
and her congressional testimony her
testimony before the Senate Judiciary
Committee major discrepancies even
though the interviews happened right
back to back and what Anita Hill tried
to lie about eventually it came out is
that she was told that if she used if
she gave her testimony
it would torpedo Clarence Thomas's
confirmation now it didn't fortunately
but there was clear motivation what she
was saying was being contradicted by
many people who worked for Clarence
Thomas for a very long time and by the
way Joe Biden himself thought that any
day he'll was lying he said this he
this just came out this was an oral
inspectors book so take it for what it's
worth but this is at least according to
Arlen Specter who was there he said
quote after this exchange Biden would
recess to the committee
Biden told me in November 1998 it was
clear to me from the way she was
answering the questions she was lying at
that point I truncated the hearing and
recessed it early for lunch Biden said I
turned to my chief of staff and said go
down and tell her lawyers that her for a
recollection is not refreshed by the
time she gets back I will be compelled
to pursue the same line of questioning
the Senator Specter did because it seems
to me she did what he said obviously
this is true anybody paying attention to
this at the time or anybody who's looked
at the history of it knows that it need
a hill lied in in multiple instances
including Joe Biden now Joe Biden goes
out and he says I'm sorry I'm sorry I
should have been nicer to Anita Hill
because what the left does is doubles
down on their dirty tricks even among
the worst accusations of all sexual
assault and rape how about Christine
Blasi Ford they went after a guy they
just pulled the Anita Hill stone almost
scene for scene again
decades later against Brett Kavanaugh
Brett Kavanaugh an unimpeachable record
federal judge for a dozen years no
allegations no accusations against him
of any sort of sexual impropriety all of
a sudden they bring up Christine Blasi
Ford who who accuses him of some vague
crime that she kept changing her story
on as some many decades ago she couldn't
even remember when it happened
contradicted herself multiple times
about key aspects of the event the Left
doubled down they still say that if you
asked people on the left today's Brett
Kavanaugh a rapist probably most of them
would say yes the honest ones among them
would say we don't care if he's a rapist
we're gonna say that he is anyway that's
a major difference there's no moral
equivalence Chris Cuomo opens up he says
there's no moral equivalence between
antia and neo-nazis there's no moral
there's no moral equivalence here
between the left and the right in how
they're engaging in violence and how
they're engaging in Paula
and how they're engaging even in dirty
tricks there's no moral equivalence now
what is motivating the left how did the
left get to such a degree of extremism
because when you look around at a lot of
the left-wing campaigns you see they're
a little bit contradictory there is a
story that just came out over the
weekend for women's powerlifting world
records were shattered over the weekend
Wow oh my goodness World Records in
squat bench press deadlift and the world
total record oh my goodness this woman
must be really really strong right she
must be like the strongest woman ever
right or she's a man which is what she
was it's this guy who calls himself Mary
Gregory
he's biologically a man and he thinks
that he's a woman and he wants to be a
woman and he's pretending to be a woman
he has destroyed all of these world
records obviously because men are
physically stronger than women and the
left is cheering the left is cheering
this on with some exceptions some
feminists realize the threat that is
posed by this transgender ideology and
they're talking out against it and by
the way when they speak out there was a
woman the editor of the feminist current
a feminist journal in Canada she spoke
out against this sort of thing she was
banned from Twitter the left broadly is
cheering this on why on earth is the
left which has championed feminism and
women's lib women's identity politics
for decades and decades why is the left
cheering on the total destruction of
women's sports because this that's what
this means if transgender people if men
who want who think that they're women or
who present themselves as women are
allowed to compete in women's sports
women will never win another sporting
event ever again ever it's not close I
know I think Millennials think that men
are yeah maybe men are stronger than
women but they're only a little bit
stronger and some women are a lot
stronger than men no that isn't true men
are much much much physically stronger
than women and transgender ideology in
competitive sports means that women will
never win anything again so now the
left which previously champion titled
nine women's sports at colleges women's
professional sports are now cheering on
the destruction of women's sports why is
that ties into another story the Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue as a young
man one of my favorite issues of
literature that was ever produced all
year long is now coming out and
celebrating their first model wearing a
bikini and the hijab apparently
apparently Sports Illustrated forgets
what the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Issue is and what it's all about but
anyway they're excited there they are
now posting the first woman in a bikini
and a hijab here she is explaining the
issue I never really felt represented
because I never could flip through a
magazine and see a girl who was wearing
a hijab six-year-old me in this same
country was in a refugee camp so to grow
up to live the American dream to come
back to Kenya and shoot for outside in
the most beautiful parts of Kenya like I
don't think that's the story that
anybody could make up just a quick
question to clarify how many
six-year-old girls living in refugee
camps are just thumbing through the
Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Issue is
that a common occurrence
i-i've I've never been there I've never
walked a mile in those shoes I just
seems to me that refugee camps don't get
a steady stream of the Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue in and even
if they did that six year old girls are
not usually thumbing through it six year
old boys on the other hand sometimes
take a little peek at the swimsuit issue
but not six-year-old girls so I'm a
little skeptical of all of that but
she's she's obviously promoting this and
being used to promote this idea but what
is the hijab the hijab is the head
covering there varying degrees of these
sort of facial coverings there's the
abaya there's the burka now what is it
because this is being heralded in the in
Sports Illustrated they write Halima
Aydin makes history is the first model
to wear a hijab in burqini in Sports
Illustrated swimsuit
the hijab is a tool used to keep women
down in many countries on earth it's not
exclusively what it is but it is
certainly partially that in Saudi Arabia
women can be lashed for going outside
without wearing their hijab and this
happened in 2016 there was a woman who
went outside with that actually without
an abaya that's the full body covering
and not only was she lashed for this not
only was she punished by the government
there were many calls for her execution
on social media a lot of posts said
quote the least punishment for her is
beheading her another one kill her and
throw her body to the dogs another one
we want blood another one we demand
utmost punishment for the state has
rules that she did not respect it is a
tool of telling women what to do
keeping them down and oppressing them in
many countries on earth now that's not
all that it is because their head
coverings are popular in every culture
everything from shawls to mantillas to
baseball caps there are our head
coverings women wear hats right but what
is the purpose of it when it's used even
in religious settings the purpose is a
sort of modesty or a recognition in the
Catholic Church for instance when you
wear a Mantia
it's a recognition of women's particular
holiness okay modesty holiness sanctity
even giving the hijab the the most
charitable read you possibly can when
has the left been interested in modesty
and holiness and sanctity the left hosts
[ __ ] walks they they host events called
shout your abortion they they mock the
church they boo God at their party
conventions are we now really supposed
to believe that just in this one example
the left is interested in modesty and
sanctity and holiness know what is this
all about
these two stories in particular the
transgender ideology obliterating
women's sports
and the left embracing women wearing the
hijab what they show is that the left is
not interested in any sort of positive
or constructive agenda they are only
interested in a destructive agenda the
way to dictate their agenda is to come
out in favor of something if you're on
the right come out in favor of a
tradition or an institution or a law or
some aspect of order physical order or
divine order or moral order and then the
left will oppose it how is the left
become so radicalized in recent years
you had Chuck Schumer voting for the
border wall in 2006
now the left is saying walls are immoral
ineffective too expensive awful terrible
things how did that happen because
Donald Trump is for the border wall and
then the border wall is as traditional
as anything it walls are the most
traditional defense in the world there's
a book that just came out there's a book
that just came out called walls it's by
a guy named David Frye it's a history of
civilization and blood and brick walls
or about the oldest thing in our
civilization it's tradition tradition
itself tradition embodied and so the
left hates him the nation quite
traditional the left hates it the
distinction between men and women now
the left has to oppose that but if
there's no distinction between men and
women then there's no separate category
for women there's no such thing as
feminism there's no such thing as women
Sports doesn't matter the left just has
to oppose as radically as possible
the tradition the left has to oppose the
established order yeah we want to go out
to [ __ ] walks we want to shout our
abortion yeah we want to free the nipple
you remember the free the nipple
campaign that was like six months ago a
big campaign on the left to allow
nipples and completely exposed breasts
on social media platforms and now six
months later yeah we love the burqini
yeah that woman needs to cover up every
inch of her body yeah Lasher Lasher we
want blood we need to execute no item it
it's hard to tell which our Saudi
Arabian mobs and
which is the American left because
there's no guiding principle there's no
bedrock there's no positive agenda
that's being promoted it is just
opposition to rigid tradition opposition
to the established order and there is no
moral equivalence there between the
people who want to build and the people
who want to burn things down that's our
show we got more to get to but we'll
have to do it tomorrow come back
get your mailbag questions in in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua Alvaro and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show Joe Biden launches his
campaign Democrats target president
Trump with endless investigations and
the clown princes of the right bachi hit
on Pete Buddha judge that's today on the
bench Shapiro show